it is here come on you Peter Peter scare
me nice to see you nice to see you too
thank you have you seen the final result
yet we want to know ya seen the whole
calendar it's so good it's so fresh I
think and really well here's the master
what is it paid out fresh and so good
emotional it is emotional and it is like
beautiful to see everyone and that kind
of proximity is English stripped down
sort of theme here yes - don't son the
dog is not the right word strip up
chopped up this bit of that soup dog
stripped up term because then you take
things away from someone and there comes
more from that person then when you put
things on you lose the person talk about
the whole experience I mean for me I've
known Peter for so long so when he
called and said this is what I'm gonna
be doing what do you think I was like
absolutely he didn't tell me that I was
going to be January so that's that's a
song do you know that must be an
Australian song happy to be January
hi I'm happy to be anything - Peter
actually I mean he's the monster and I
don't say that lightly
I want you all see what I talk about the
the other women in this calendar and
talk about this caliber of
in his calendar that's very difficult
and very dangerous the choice for the
calendar was I'm more or less I said
that in the other interviews a few weeks
ago that I went people to ask me what is
idea behind the casting and I said
sister all the woman on the way I've I
mean I'm doing this for life try the
wild and this way all the woman I would
have asked to marry me at one point with
over half the balls with no reason I
love Pro 40 and more than I should and
more than I how can I say that a lot you
find out information like that how does
that make you feel flattered very
flattered and yes she said yes very much
to see the calendar thank you for your
time